[Musique]
politique ce soir nos carnets de
campagne nous emmène à paris dans la
sixième circonscription où se présentent
l'une des filles de jean marie le pen
marine 24 ans novice en politique mais
fidèle vous allez le voir aux idées de
papa
il y a d'abord eu le chef jean-marie une
vie consacrée à la politique puis marie
caroline la grande huit années de combat
récompensé par un siège au conseil
régional
aujourd'hui marine la benjamine tout
aussi blonde que ça sort tout aussi
imprégné de civisme familiale baptême
électoral un brin précoce peut être
objectivement 24 ans c'est une vie assez
courte mais subjectivement nous avons
été confrontés en qualité de fille de
jean marie le pen à un grand nombre
d'obstacles dans notre vie et peut-être
cela nous a forgé un caractère
plus combatifs et nous a donné une
expérience certaine du sens des choses
et de la valeur des choses conseil de
famille échange de recettes le xviie
arrondissement est une circonscription
difficile le fief de bernard pons vous
du diamant a tendance à penser que c'est
pas une construction facile parce que
[Musique]
foncier
est implanté depuis longtemps mais je
crois que les gens sont prêts à ça prêt
à changer
j'ai un meilleur accueil de culte vendu
85 j'en accueille beaucoup plus
sympathique annulé
l'arrivée sur le terrain enfin plus
exactement à l'un des sièges du parti
marine a dû déserter la campagne une
semaine cloué sur un lit d'hôpital crise
d'appendicite aiguë la candidate est
convalescente pas de marché ni de
tournée des popotes avant quelques jours
il va falloir muscler pour compenser le
handicap
alors je pensais faire un truc comme ça
avec photo du candidat donc marine le
pen
votre candidat autre indication sur la
6e circonscription et avec derrière un
argumentaire je pensais m'être notamment
voter utile c'est voter pour vos idées
parce que j'ai un pion 17e session ils
sont assez influent ses paroles par
l'argument du vote utile est développé
dans les repères
la stratégie haro sur bernard pons un
candidat que l'opinion situe à la droite
du rpr
monsieur pons bénéficie d'une image qui
est une fausse image et que je cherche à
ak c'est moi je cherche à faire
comprendre aux gens et aux électeurs du
xviie qui croient voter pour quelqu'un
qui n'est pas celui qui se dit être moi
personnellement je ne fais pas de
campagne au niveau des hommes ou des
femmes qui se présentent je défends mes
idées je crois que les électrices et les
électeurs du 17e ne connaissent bien je
suis député de cette circonscription
depuis 1981
connu élu dans un fauteuil il y a cinq
ans bernard pons avait obtenu 66 % des
voix au premier tour
après mars fin de la parenthèse marine
le pen retourne aux affaires le cabinet
de l'avocat du front national l'avenir
électoral cela dépendra de papa mais
marine aura t-elle réellement envie de
se faire un prénom en politique
[Musique]